en piste pour les nuits fauves peut-on
le lire peut-il le dire en tout cas lui
les cris cyril collard c'est une colère
bonsoir ça fait math sup et maths sup
dock de mac
et puis un jour 179 en a eu ras-le-bol
fadi je m'étais trompé d'existence
étaient partis non
oui je suis parti j'ai abandonné tout le
monde des études jour au lendemain non
tu si on dit du jour au lendemain c'est
ça se fait pas ça c'est quand même en
quelques mois ouais mais je suis parti à
porto rico puis j'ai commencé à écrire
pas bien et puis merci
et puis et puis j'ai aussi changé de
manière de vivre changer de gens autour
de moi changer de sexualiser m'a pas
complètement un peu amoindrie venir
alors en volant de porto rico donc a été
assistant de pialat sur le loup sur
police sur quoi oui je l'école j'ai
connu fiala à la faim de loup et j'ai
fait avec lui à nos amours et police
ensuite ça fait des courts métrages cplg
la blonde qui a été primé dans nos loges
alger la blanche la blanche et des
pelles weiler pas mal de festivals
épitaphe et dkny tafer carte de séjour
ce que j'ai fait douze france de carte
de séjour j'ai fait deux clips pour
graziella de michel way
et puis les portemanteaux aussi et puis
kassiry un championnat ivoirien
voilà qu'a fait une émission de télé qui
s'appelle remet quand vous voulez qu'ils
étaient supprimées malheureusement ça
fait un premier livre qui s'appelait
condat les amours d'un très beau très
beau teams et pilotes avaient fait un
deuxième qui s'appelle les nuits fauves
ça parle de sexe faut bien le dire pour
commencer c'est à dire tu dis je suis
accroché au sexe comme les calmes et à
la drogue oui je crois qu'il parle de
gens qui
sur qui effectivement le sexe pèse comme
une espèce de fatalité en masturbation
sans arrêt performances sexuelles
étonnant c'est possible ça je vais avec
chapeau di sano sur un lit ils se
branchent quoi il va pour s'endormir is
branly cela vise brand israel moi c'est
pas possible faire exagèrent je
n'exagère pas beaucoup non métissé
l'écriture c'est aussi une concentration
des choses pour être bisexuelle bon
willy bisexualité et toi moi aussi il
faut aussi parce que c'est lui ou c'est
toi écoute l'autobiographie c'est
toujours un truc boucle c'est la
question qu'on pose à tous les gens qui
auraient fait relire en général tu sais
ce que je vais être l'on va pas manquer
de la pause et ouais bon c'est un roman
c'est un roman parce que parce que je
revendique qui a une écriture que c'est
littéraire maintenant les choses dont je
parle
même si elles sont pas toutes
exact il y en a qui sont inventés mais
en général ce sont des choses qui sont
passés par mois ces endroits dont tu
parles comme ça ces souterrains de la
ville en face et des espèces de back
room en plein air c'est ou faisant droit
comme ça où les gens soient et moi je
décris un endroit que l'écart entre près
de la gare d'austerlitz mais entre
austerlitz et entre le monde sur 800
pompes bercy c'est pas très grave
l'endroit où ça se trouve pas ce que je
vais pas faire un itinéraire fléché
mariés non séparés guide simplement
c'est l'idée aussi que condescendant un
autre ordre que les choses sont pas
pareils cas la surface coquet l'espagne
ce parce que plus il ya un type qui
vient chercher vous plaisir immédiat qui
vient chercher autre chose que ce qu'ils
trouvent dans l'est dans les hiérarchies
de la surface un opus c'est un autre un
autre internaute
les pouvoirs sont pas les mêmes la
communication est pas là mais y'a pas de
mots c'est juste des frôlements juste du
sexe et la brute coiffe ses du sexe
avait un beau c'est surtout aussi une
manière de d'arriver à satisfaire ses
fantasmes
c'est là souvent moi ouais ça m'arrive
cet arrêt la dernière fois cet été quand
royal à moi ah ouais quand même
alors un jour le personnage ou toi
découvrait ce que vous êtes séropositif
ça se passe comment cette découverte à
quelle occasion tu fais le test
votre seul test tu fais mon personnage
je le dire il le fait par simplement
parce que le test n'a existé et c'est
quand même assez récent et c'est
finalement la peur elle et l'angoissé
les surtout plus grande avant je vois
pas ce que avant qu'il dit c'est pour
moi je vais y avoir droit à quoi
peut-être que c'est parce que parce que
celle éducation judéo-chrétienne cette
fête de conscience de la faute il
fallait la culpabilité mois comme tu
disais je suis parti d'une j'avais une
voie tracée qui était une autre et puis
je changer j'ai bifurqué
et puis peut-être qu'il ya une faute une
idée de la faute qui arrive comme ça et
que je me suis dit voilà c'est pour moi
mais finalement quand le test est fait
d'une certaine manière on a moins peur
et quand est dictée positive mais c'est
une espèce de lutte qui commence mais
pas vraiment justement on y viendra sous
moi je trouve que enfin le personnage va
partir du moment où il sait qu'il est
séropositif
on pourrait penser qu'il va se mettre à
vivre calmement qui valait à la campagne
boire du bon lait de vache
et puis qu'est-ce qui fait il prend
jamais autant de cours qui prend jamais
autant de braun et il sort jamais autant
la nuit comment ça se fait ça c'est
suicidaire complètement ça non je crois
que c'est une évolution
d'abord la lutte et laissez pas quelque
chose d'extérieur c'est pas c'est pas
des vitamines et les complexes et à
l'intérieur de soi la lutte
et puis si tu deviens vu dans le livre
que effectivement il ya des histoires de
coco début et il ya de la drogue mais ça
se termine pas comme ça ils abandonnent
tous un peu à peu le
est séropositif c'est pas une exclusion
ça peut enfin a priori on aura envie de
se changer un peu des voitures non
pourquoi
sinon on a envie de vivre c'est tout
votre rythme voyez une fille au milieu
de tout ça c'est une ville qui a 17 ans
et que elle elle est complètement
romantique elle n'est pas du tout dans
dans cet univers de l'accélération de la
multiplication parce que je crois que ça
c'est quelque chose qui est vraiment
important dans livre c'est la confusion
quoi c'est que ce soit de narrateur que
ce soit sabine djamel ces personnages là
c'est des gens divisé quoi qui sont un
peu coupé en morceaux et une confusion
la fois affective idéologie géologique
usgs est claire là leur mentalité c'est
des petits bouts collés les uns équivaut
aux idéologies différentes coller les
uns à côté des autres et elle au
contraire elle et elle est amoureuse de
ce mec et elle veut que lui et il l est
elle accepte le risque de la
contamination
elle accepte pas vraiment cyril parce
qu'au départ la première fois le
personnage ne dit pas il lui dit pas
c'est quand même
une forme d' assassinat en quelque sorte
non de faire l'amour avec quelqu'un
quand on est séropositif sans lui dire
bah il sauf que dans le livre je crois
que c'est clairement dit que ça se
termine bien puisque le film n'est pas
et on aurait du mal se terminer mal se
terminer mais je crois que c'est le bon
là on en revient toujours à l'histoire
de la faute et pourquoi est ce qu il lui
dit pas pourquoi tu me dis pas
simplement parce que dans ce cycle sera
que bah ouais parce que dans ce test
d'accélération de sa vie c'est un sien
un truc complètement gelé dit morcelé
divisé qui va très vite tout d'impôt de
sept filets l'impression que que
vraiment c'est une histoire d'amour ils
y croient bon il n'ose pas lui dire tout
simplement ces sénateurs en fait là si
elle souffre plus du fait qu'ils soient
bisexuelle que dit la séropositivité en
vérité elle en souffre beaucoup plus
parce que lui il arrive pas à se
détacher des garçons et elle le fait mal
il a fait tourner en bourrique disons
pour et il ya une chose qui est pas mal
dans le bouquin c'est que l'histoire
d'amour est racontée sur répondeur
ça c'est assez moderne c'est à dire que
en yvon nouveau mais c'est de leur
histoire que les messages qu'elle lui
laisse le répondeur je crois que ça fait
aussi partie comme la maladie comme la
confusion comme les confusions ça fait
partie du
de cette espèce de kaléidoscope de la
modernité pour moi rien moment qu'elle
sait assez fort il ya six amis qui se
fait bastonner sans doute tout cas un
problème et des néo-nazis et puis tu
remplis une seringue et tu dis je vais
lui je vais lui envoyer mon sens pourri
dans les veines là ça devient grave
maintenant pour nom je trouve que on on
a à moi j'ai en moi
la violence et j'ai en moi des désirs
l'engagement politique ou fou contre je
suis dans le fascisme je ne sais pas pas
le fascisme et je suis c'est la
littérature je ne dis pas que je vais le
faire mais c'est vrai qu'on peut penser
des choses comme ça et et l'idée de
l'idée d'aller avec une seringue compte
un fasciste je vois pas ce que je trouve
ça
vous savez un anormal je trouve parfois
normal mais je pense qu'on peut y penser
oui ça c'est un monde assez
crépusculaire quand même c'est à dire il
n'y a pas beaucoup d'amour d'amitié
encore moins mystique moi c'est quand
même très froides crépusculaire non je
suis pas daccord partir du moment où le
narrateur il se pose c'est quand même
écrit noir sur blanc
je ne sais pas aimé dire quelqu'un qui
dit je sais pas aimé ça prouve quand
même qui se pose la question qu'est ce
que l'amour c'est au centre de sa vie
reconnaître ses incapacités ses doutes
c'est quand même aussi un privilège de
l'homme qui pense bien le type qui a que
des certitudes
c'est un facho et les amis comment ils
ont réagi aux livres
62 ans à paris qui savait pas que
j'avais des problèmes de séropositivité
paris c'était quand même des gens qui
sinon a pris un jour en recevant
tambourin way regardant son visage et
moi que ça je crois que ça fait des
catégories
il ya des gens qui s'en vont des gens
qui restent
et puis
et si c'était à refaire alors durant 79
ouais maths spé match y de m c'était à
refaire du si tu connaissais la fin de
l'histoire
tu prend le même chemin écoute c'est une
bonne question à laquelle j'ai jamais
réfléchi ça changera rien qui nuira mais
tu peux appeler sir qu'est-ce que tu le
ferais aussi c'est bien je suis
quelqu'un qui je suis quelqu'un quand
même d'assez libre j'ai à peu près
toujours fait ce que je voulais donc si
j'ai fait ça c'est peut-être que j'ai
réalisé qu'on est à venir plus bas
comment est en écoute je vais tourner un
film en descente
j'ai des idées de bouquins
je vais peut-être faire un film avec ce
livre et puis
peut-être que je vais apprendre à aimer
un peu plus